[Musique]
nous sommes le 11 octobre 2016 faisons
un point avec celles et ceux qui font
l'actualité dans le département
bienvenue pour ce nouveau numéro du 7-8
les invités aujourd'hui vous entendrez
pascal tirer un an ferme et accordina
trice du don d'organes à l'hôpital
mignon à versailles elle est avec nous à
l'occasion de la soirée débat organisée
au cinéma roxana versailles autour de la
sortie du film réparer des vivants qui
traitent justement de cette peau ni de
cette problématique
et puis nous irons à la rencontre que
christophe les le nouveau directeur du
cercle nautique à versailles il nous
livre à ses objectifs pour le club et on
débute aujourd'hui avec le soin la
soirée débat autour du film réparer les
vivants qui se déroulera le 14 octobre à
20h15 au cinéma roxane à versailles le
but du débat sensibiliser le public au
don d'organes voici un extrait du film
votre fille simon a eu un grave accident
de la route mais je comprends rien
quand vous le voyez tout me semble
normal c'est uniquement grâce aux
machines que vous avez vues dans sachant
pas si on arrête ces machines son coeur
s'arrêtera aussi c'est délicat mais il
faut que j'apporte quelque chose avec
vous cette situation permet d'envisager
attendent un organe
si cette démarche mise en place c'est
uniquement dans le but d'aider des
malades qui sont en attente à marianne
vous savez ce que je vais vous dire que
c'est mon heure plus tôt c'est pas
survécu au coeur d'avoir clair c'est
votre décision mais un coeur ça ne se
trouve pas comme ça ils saluent
et avec nous ce soir pour en parler
pascal tirer bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
infirmier encore des matrices des
prélèvements d'organes et tissus au
centre hospitalier de versailles on a pu
voir un petit extrait du film dites moi
c'est quoi c'est la force de ce chiffre
alors ce film il est tiré d'un livre de
maylis de kerangal qui a été publiée a
déjà plusieurs années livres qu'il a
plus de 400000 exemplaires
à la suite de ce livre il ya eu une
pièce de théâtre qui a été adapté aussi
et là le film a été adapté beaucoup de
réalisateurs étaient motivés pour
adapter ce livre au cinéma et finalement
nous allons avoir la version qui sort le
2 novembre alors nous avons une version
en avant-première à versailles le 14 le
14 octobre c'est un film qui est d'une
grande force parce qu'il aborde tous les
tous les sujets alors évidemment ça peut
sembler extrêmement triste mais c'est un
film qui est
qui reflète parfaitement la réalité il a
été réalisé avec beaucoup de
professionnels
il présente plusieurs avantages c'est
que déjà effectivement il est dans la
réalité purement médical de ce mouvement
depuis l'admission de ce2 sinon à ce
jeune homme à l'hôpital jusqu'au
prélèvement de son coeur il présente
aussi sa vie un petit peu avant comment
était ce jeune homme est le point qui
est quand même extrêmement important
c'est qu'ils présentent aussi la vie de
la personne qui va recevoir ce cas alors
pourquoi avoir décidé d'organiser autour
de ce film une soirée débat au cinéma
roxana versa explique mans alors déjà le
remercie c'est important de sensibiliser
je remercie sinimale qui a répondu tout
de suite extrêmement présents à notre
demande il y en a d'autres à auxi
vaucresson il y aura aussi à
saint-cyr-l'ecole rambouillet
le don d'organes le prélèvement
d'organes c'est un sujet qui est encore
un peu
difficile à aborder qui n'est pas
suffisamment abordé dans les familles il
ya encore des tabous il ya encore des
choses qui circulent qui ne sont pas
justes comme le rendu du corps ou aux
proches comme son image de mutilation de
choses comme ça et c'est important de
profiter de ce film qui je le répète est
parfaitement réel pour expliquer aux
gens ce en quoi ça consiste la mort
cérébrale et puis toutes les démarches
qui peuvent être faites et puis lors de
ce débat vous serez accompagné d'une
personne qui a déjà accueilli en don
d'organes c'est important d'avoir son
témoignage abbas est formidable monsieur
m 6 4 quelqu'un qui témoigne extrêmement
souvent il a été greffé du coeur à 50
ans ça fait plus de dix ans maintenant
qu'il est en pleine forme
effectivement le fait d'avoir quelqu'un
qui témoigne bas que effectivement la
grèce ça marche bon il ya effectivement
quelques fois des personnes qui décèdent
après leur grève quand elles ont attendu
trop longtemps pour diverses raisons
mais ça marche ça fonctionne et monsieur
m6 car on est la preuve vivante la
difficulté qu'on va surtout abordé avec
le spectateur c'est le nom
positionnement des personnes c'est à
dire que quand une famille n'a pas les
connaissances du la volonté du défunt
c'est très compliqué de prendre la
décision c'est toujours dans des
circonstances très brutal la personne va
très bien le matin et elle en mort
cérébrale à 22h c'est un choc terrible
un son extrêmement difficile à
comprendre et quand la personne décédée
ne s'est pas prononcé les proches bien
souvent disent non par méconnaissance de
cette volonté c'est dur d'en discuter en
famille pourquoi les femmes ne sont pas
ou je crois que la tendance bouge
énormément on fait beaucoup
d'informations auprès des jeunes etc qui
sont un bon vecteur de relais dans les
familles il ya encore beaucoup de gens
qui pensent qu'après 70 ans peut pas
être prélevés et puis
c'est compliqué c'est compliqué alors
c'est un peu curieux parce que les
enfants font des testament obsèques font
part de leur volonté à leurs enfants
quand quand ils vieillissent mais c'est
un sujet qu'il n'aborde pas peut-être
simplement parce qu'ils n'y pensent pas
et les personnes que vous recevez à
versailles est ce que vous sentez qu'au
fameux ils sont plus sensibles à ce
sujet où il ya encore du travail à faire
il ya encore un gros vrai travail à
faire mais encore un vrai gros travail à
faire
on a quand même en ile-de-france bons
sauts versailles on a 25 % de refus sur
l'île de france on est à plus de 40 % de
refus et je dire 5 % de refus en moins
ça fait énormément de greffe en plus il
y avait en début d'année 2016 plus de
15000 personnes en attente on réalise à
peu près 5700 greffe à l'année mais ça
ne correspond pas au nombre de personnes
qui vont s'inscrire pendant cette année
donc en moyenne on compte vingt mille
personnes en attente de greffe d'organe
vital et quand tu vois là et salle vidal
droite le mot exprime bien la chose
c'est extrêmement important alors il ya
une carte aussi qu'on peut avoir pour
dire qu'on est donneur d'organes ça se
passe comment alors la carte n'est pas
un document officiel comme peut l'être
votre carte d'identité c'est malgré tout
la preuve d'un engagement c'est à dire
que comme la personne à sa cape dans son
portefeuille en général c'est qu'elle en
a parlé à ses proches mais qui n y en a
pas parlé parce que pour des raisons x y
nous ça nous fait un point d'ancrage
pour la discussion c'est la preuve d'un
certain engagement après jeu il est
important de dire aussi aux personnes
qui le souhaitent il existe un registre
national des refus que personne ne
connait il ya une centaine peu à peu
près cent mille personnes d'inscrites
dessus les gens ne le connaissent pas et
si on est contre et si on ne veut pas
qu'on nous en clair soit prélevé après
notre décès on peut s'inscrire sur ce
registre national des refus que nous
coordinateur on est obligé d'interroger
on a des réponses par fax en cinq
minutes on sait que la dalle où la
personne s'est prononcé contre on ne va
même pas posé la question à la famille
et ce registre il faut qu'on le fasse
connaître parce que la loi a été un
petit peu modifié on l'est tous donneurs
potentiels mais elle va beaucoup
s'appuyer sur le registre national des
refus donc il faut qu'elle soit connue
et pour finir dites moi on peut donner
son
ces organes de quel âge à quel âge alors
si les petits enfants malheureusement ça
arrive ça arrive on peut aller jusqu'à
des âges un peu avancé on peut très bien
dans la mesure où on va très vite pour
avoir tous les examens on est dans
l'urgence vitale donc on a les scanners
on a les échographies très très vite
mais rien n'empêche c'est une personne
qui a un bon état général de prélever
des organes ou de 80 ans rien n'empêche
de greffe est quelqu'un qui a un bon
état général à 75 ont déplu au début de
la greffe donc effectivement au prélève
plus tard pour bien évidemment greffer
des personnes plus tard et pour finir ce
que vous auriez une phrase à dire à nos
téléspectateurs
alors la recommandation la phrase c'est
effectivement d'en discuter avec ses
proches de faire part de sa volonté et
puis dans sa réflexion parce que c'est
une réflexion c'est pas quelque chose
qu'on peut prendre la décision en trois
secondes et demi il faut se rappeler
qu'on est tous donneurs potentiels et
bien évidemment je ne souhaite
absolument de mal à personne à aucun de
téléspectateurs on peut tous un jour
être receveur potentiel et ce à quelques
pas dans la réflexion il faut y penser
merci pascal thiery je rappelle que ce
vendredi que 14 octobre à une soirée
débat est organisé après la projection
du film réparer les vivants merci merci
beaucoup tout autre sujet de l'aviron à
présent il est le nouvel homme du cercle
nautique à versailles christophe plée
chef d'entreprise de 48 ans succède à
denis landart décédé cet été adhérent au
club depuis 1981 il s'occupait
principalement de l'entraînement des
cadets et des minimes
christophe pellet nous livre ses
objectifs pour le club il est au micro
de michael et demi d'euros d'abord je
succède à des grands présidents c'est à
dire que
mais quatre prédécesseurs ont bâti le
club ils ont fait en sorte que nous
ayons des locaux des locaux ils nous ont
fait en sorte que nous ayons des moyens
ils ont fait en sorte que nous ayons des
professionnels qui encadrent les jeunes
ils ont multiplié le nombre de membres
par deux aujourd'hui c'est 450 licenciés
600 scolaires entre 100 et 200 personnes
qui viennent dans le cadre de stages de
team building donc c'est une grosse
association
c'est une grosse machine et mes
prédécesseurs ont réussi à monter cette
machine et à la faire arriver là où elle
est pour autant je n'ai pas
l'organisation ni le temps qu'avait
notamment denis landart mon prédécesseur
donc on va réorganiser un petit peu le
comité de direction nous allons
fonctionner plus avec des commissions et
des délégations pour pouvoir être plus
réactif on a plusieurs objectifs à la
fois pour la compétition du club à la
fois pour les loisirs du club organisait
plus d'événements pour eux multipliez
l'encadrement pour nos jeunes et puis on
a un objectif sur le sport scolaire et
le sport universitaire on on souhaite
développer nos partenariats avec les
collèges versaillais nous faisons déjà
venir le collège foch toutes les classes
de 5e viennent pratiquer l'aviron le
jeudi matin sur le grand canal on
souhaite démultiplier sa
inscrire de nouveaux programmes il ya un
programme de la fédération rame en
cinquième qui fonctionne extrêmement
bien on souhaite le développer dans ces
collèges là et dans les collèges
alentours il ya des feature thomas
barrau qu'ici à versailles et vous
voulez les formes est encore plus fort
qu'il le devienne je crois qu'il ya des
futurs thomas baruch non seulement au
club mais également dans versailles
également dans les communes alentour on
se doit de former ces gens là on se doit
de les accueillir et les amener jusqu'au
plus haut niveau et de le faire
comprendre que c'est un chemin qui les
mènera vers l'excellence à la fois
sportive et à la fois professionnel et
quelle est la prochaine grande échéance
de
du cercle nautique de versailles alors
là on rentre dans une ce qu'on appelle
dans la saison hivernale donc sondé ce
sont des courses qui se passe plutôt des
courses assez longue il n'ya il ya des
courses maintenant à peu près tous les
quinze jours dans les jeunes catégories
la prochaine grosse échéance sera notre
assemblée générale fin fin janvier qui
va donner le départ de la nouvelle
organisation et le d'un point de vue
sportif les courses commenceront
vraiment à partir du printemps
merci de nous avoir suivis c'est la fin
de ce sept huit invités on se retrouve
demain à la même heure pour une nouvelle
édition bonne soirée
[Musique]